i've talked to doctors that have been
fired for saying something online that
didn't fit the orthodoxy of the
institution
as well as a a fear of the cancer
culture and fear of people coming after
them and feeling people uncovering their
license i mean they're scare doctors are
so easily scared that's how we end up
with the opioid epidemic because doctors
started getting
criminally prosecuted for inadequate
treatment of pain
they were getting fined and going to
that's not malpractice that's criminal
and civil liability and we all froze we
stopped prescribing for pain patients
and sent them all to the pain management
people and their position was
pain is what the patient says it is pain
controls what the patient says it is you
don't even need a doctor just ask the
patient what they need and set it set it
off the counter we'll have the starbucks
point of what you want they were doing
that in florida at one point and that's
how you got the opioid epidemic
at some stage of a liberal democracy
that is flourishing you will have
allowed in so many crazy ideas you will
have gotten so fat on freedom and doing
what you want and living as you wish
which is mostly good that then you will
have drag queen story hour you will have
the surgeon general saying that a
biological man is a female you will have
all this stuff like it's just the end
game in a way of this which as a
california
liberal i think is how you describe
yourself is a sad position to have to
defend
this is again back to keeping reality
coming in reality eventually comes to
bear reality has a way of coming in and
you can say all the abraham lincoln has
a famous some of this must have been
going on in the civil war too because
abraham lincoln has a very it wasn't a
famous quote as a quote that caught my
attention as it pertains to our current
moment
he came into the cabinet meeting one day
and he you know chase and all those guys
are there and he goes gentlemen
if i say
an elephant's trunk is a leg
hear this yeah how many legs does that
elephant have and they all go oh five i
guess and he goes no
four
calling it a leg doesn't make it a leg
and i thought that's this moment you can
call you can say anything you want it
doesn't make it so you're trying to make
it so
it won't be it just isn't you can't make
things so but there is interesting thing
you said here too also which is you
talked about the the limits of freedom
at the same time as we're sort of
defending freedom i'd not really thought
about that because in a way the way we
got here is because of sort of
ex in a weird way excessive freedom to
the point that reality was was uh
subjugated you know it's more freedom to
instead of freedom from right so you
want freedom from well it reminds me of
right it reminds you of the the
tolerance and intolerance it's
intolerance in the name of tolerance
it's it's a weird this is a weird spot
uh i do feel though that the excesses of
freedom and brought us to the place
where freedom from yes needs to be
defended so uh
i know that the
well this we're actually all bouncing
around through a lot of the stuff that's
in your book it is in the book but let
me just say that if the book is
written by me and my daughter uh
she is very woke uh and she actually
helped me understand some of her point
of view i really got to a better
understanding of where she sees these
things uh and it's designed for a 15
year old and their parents essentially
it's something you should leave out on
your coffee table if you have middle
late teenagers how to navigate
relationships it was originally about
consent because back when we before
covet consent was something
in the heels of the metoo movement was
very very important conversation and
adolescents were very confused about it
we realized as we wrote the book it
really is about how to navigate
relationships generally so so to that
point so you just described your
daughter as woke which i think a lot of
people are watching this video in fact
in fact we were on megyn kelly and megan
went i think you're the first woke
person i've ever had on this show and
because she launched into her patriarchy
thing oh yeah and uh and megan was great
she was very gracious and she pushed
back and they had a nice nice that
that's good
that's a night that exactly and then my
daughter i shouldn't be on these kinds
of shows like if you want to make your
point where you want to make it to the
echo chamber make it to megyn kelly
that's where you should be making it if
you want to if you want to bring people
on board with your point of view what
kind of attention has that caused you
because every night every single person
watching this is going through some
version of that myself including
someone woke in your family um it
actually really improved our situation
because i think there was a
we were forced to to really clarify our
positions to one another by talking to
somebody else
and uh i it helped me help me and by the
way i started admiring how she thought
about things you can admire people that
have ideas that are different than yours
i don't i feel like for her reality will
come in a little more and she'll adjust
this something but i i admire what she's
thinking about and that she's struggling
with these things and i get it i get it
i don't agree with it but i get it and
so that's that's how i would approach it
so without making this about her
specifically although if you want to if
you want to feel free well we have no
issues generally speaking if you were to
say to a woke person there are
biological differences between you'd
have to you'd have to be using your
emails you'd have to say look i'm not a
biological determinism right you'd have
to find the just get the common ground
quick just go look i agree gender is a
construct and it's not about strictly
the biology but and i'd actually put
this in the book this is this is where i
was pushing back kind of hard in the
book i was like i'm a physician right
yeah i i have to know the the sex
hormones and what they're doing
biologically i have to know that and by
the way if i'm going to deal with a
transgender they are getting very
powerful medication from maybe me that
are hormones that are not being produced
because of the
hormone because of the chromosomal
situation that's a medical treatment i
need to know what i'm doing and that's
my main that's actually my main thing
about
treatment and transgender right now is i
don't think my profession is doing a
good job the job should be the right
treatment for the right patient at the
right moment and we have not figured
that out they're all getting everything
the same and that is never as good
that's never good what do you think
happened i guess at the the psychiatric
layer when it comes to this i'm guessing
i'm just talking about push all that
aside and just say somebody's going to
get treatment uh you know when do you do
it and who do you give it to who's the
right one to give it to and how do you
determine that that none of that is just
everybody gets the treatment no
questions asked that's it that's that's
not how you do medicine right so then
what happened okay so more broadly and
what happened at the medical layer where
you know
the same thing
same thing that happened uh during coven
same thing happened is my physician
freezes they freeze and they're afraid
to do anything they're afraid to say
anything so i something i didn't know
until covet is that so many of my peers
are
employees now so they're fearful of
doing something out of line for their
employer they're that's interesting so
there's less that just have their own
practices
it doesn't exist so if you say something
wrong the employer will fire you i've
talked to doctors that have been fired
for saying something online that didn't
fit the orthodoxy of the institution
as well as a fear of the canceled
culture and fear of people coming after
them and feeling people encumbering
their license i mean they're scare
doctors are so easily scared that's how
we end up with the opioid epidemic
because doctors started getting
criminally prosecuted for inadequate
treatment of pain they were getting
fined and going to it's not malpractice
that's criminal and civil liability and
we all froze we we stopped prescribing
for pain patients and sent them all to
the pain management people and their
position
was pain is what the patient says it is
pain controls what the patient says it
is you don't even need a doctor just ask
the patient what they need and set it
set it off the counter we'll have the
starbucks point of what you want they
were doing that in florida at one point
and that's how you got the opioid
epidemic so relating this to the to the
trans issues it's one of the issues of
the day and yeah and since you were
talking to your daughter i mean we seem
unable to have that basic thing but i
get it you can you can have it there are
soft ways to have it i know you can
once you're into it you're going to
disagree on that sure but when you see
the surge i don't know if you saw it the
surgeon general of the united states
sending out a tweet that rachel levine
is our first four star female blah blah
blah
she i'll use her preferred pronouns
because i'm a nice guy she's not female
but you see the surge in generals i get
i get there there is a
there's a lot of orthodoxy around the
language did she say female or woman or
woman female that's
because i have no i have no problem with
calling a a transgender woman a woman i
have no end because she i'm not i agree
but but if when you start saying you
know you start trying to trying to
adjust the biology it's like
that and then i'm then i'm concerned
that then it's like how do i treat this
person how do i know what i'm dealing
with i mean i
do i do i
as a gynecologist should i be treating
men is that as a proc as a
as a
as a urologist should i pretend that
women have a prostate
screen them for prostate cancer because
they want me to
i hate to tell you what i think most of
their answers would be you've got to be
kidding not really no no no listen i am
very concerned about transphobia and
about the i i don't want those people to
i don't want anybody with those people i
don't want anybody with any conditions
to feel marginalized or not a part of i
want everyone to get along that's my
thing and so you know people want to use
certain language i'll try to figure it
out i'll try to go with it but i'm a
biologist and there's certain things i
just have to have in order to do my work
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell